foreign
hey everyone I know you must be aware of
the situation where you have to pay a
small but certain amount as a fee while
making any transactions over the
blockchain but did you know that iota's
tangle is one platform where
transactions occur without fees
interesting isn't it but here's the
catch iota's tangle is not a blockchain
so what is it well to answer such
questions simply learn has created a
full-fledged video on iotis Tangle that
will help you understand all its
Concepts systematically and precisely so
without any further delay let's get
started but before moving forward please
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit that Bell icon for more
such interesting videos moving on let's
look at the concepts you will be
exploring in this topic first you will
understand what is Iota following that
you will explore what is tangle in
iota's tangle and then you will come
across the working of Iota and iota's
architecture after that you will see
some features of iota's tangle and the
impact of Iota in real life
so what is iotis tangle iota's tangle is
a distributed Ledger that is open cost
free and scalable and is made to
facilitate frictionless data and value
movement the Iota network is the
backbone of iot and is designed for the
internet of things and has low resource
requirements tamper-proof data and
fee-free microtransactions the internet
of everything is a network for
exchanging money and data between
devices and this distributed Ledger is
the first one designed for it also Iota
has no blocks no miners policy which
means you validate two additional
transactions when you send an Iota
transaction and this enables Iota to get
around blockchain's financial and
scalability constraints in short Iota is
positioned to be a key player in the
upcoming Industrial Revolution by
facilitating business interactions
between machines and connecting the
economies of people and machines but
this raises a question what does the
tangle stand for in iota's tangle Well
iota's network is called the tangle it
permanently documents the data and value
exchange it guarantees that the data is
reliable and cannot be changed or erased
it's kind of a digital Ledger that is
replicated on all nodes in an Iota
Network all the data in the tangle is
stored in objects called transactions
and when a transaction is attached to
the tangle it cannot be changed and is
immutable in short it contains the
current transaction history and is the
single source of Truth
so now that you know about the basics of
iota's Tangle let me take you through
the working of it first let's make this
clear that Iota is not a blockchain it's
a dag which stands for directed a cyclic
graph dag is used to agreeing on all of
the transactions inside their tangle
though dags are similar to blockchain
they are still way faster and can scale
better seeming to be the next evolution
of blockchain Technology
in Iota Network each transaction is
called a node which are connected to
each other using edges or arcs directed
stated that the graph as a direction and
the acyclic part states that the graph
always continues in One Direction and
never has a loop now each node will try
to point to at least two other past
nodes but you can find up to eight
once that node has two other future
nodes directed toward it it will be a
confirmed transaction and this whole
network of nodes is called tangle
and the more people use Iota the faster
it gets because you have those two nodes
pointing towards your transaction faster
but what is iota's architecture for
those transactions to take place iota's
architecture includes the following
basic components clients users who send
transactions to nodes on the Iota
Network such as wallets applications and
Etc can join the tangle nodes devices
that are connected and in charge of
maintaining the tangles Integrity Iota
is a network made up of these devices
tangle the tangle stores all of its data
in objects referred to as transactions a
transaction becomes immutable and
unchangeable once it is linked to the
tangle well now that you have understood
all the concepts of iota's Tangle let me
tell you some unique features of iota's
tangle
first it is highly scalable unlike
blockchain Alternatives Iota uses a dag
or directed a cyclic graph data
structure that enables transactions to
be added in parallel second is fast
transactions Iota transactions are
confirmed within minutes unlike other
cryptocurrencies whose transaction
confirmation rates depend on the crowd
third is low resource requirements as
discussed in this video Iota is designed
to enable devices to participate in a
low energy Network such as sensors
fourth is finality within seconds the
approval of genuine messages happens
extremely swiftly and effectively
fifth is zero fee transaction as we know
this is the USP of iota's tangle if it
sends one cent it receives one cent and
if it sends a million dollars it
receives a million dollars
and sixth is distributed Iota is a
globally distributed Network that is
resilient and robust against the tax
in continuing this let me take you
through the impact of iota's tangle in
the real world
first is social impact the Iota
Foundation encourages the utilization of
technology to improve Society at large
it focuses on sustainability harnessing
the power of iot to manage natural
resources more efficiently
an identity introducing digital identity
to people Beyond borders and
citizen-centric governance to enable
more transparent and inclusive
governance
second is global trade
Iota can make it easier for businesses
governments logistic companies and end
users to work together while fostering
trust it focuses on track and Trace
sharing updates throughout the supply
chain with provenance data from the
source Customs and Border management
update trade certifications for
International Exchange and digital Twins
turn any product container or
Consignment into a digital twin
and the third one is unifying digital
identity Iota aims to provide trust
between individuals organizations and
things it focuses on self-sovereign
identity a borderless digital identity
that anyone can verify the identity of
things identities to allow devices to
prove their authenticity and
specifications
Regulatory Compliance digital identities
that meet data privacy regulations like
gdpr well this brings us to the end of
this video on iota's Tangle if you liked
this video then please do like this
video And subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more such interesting
updates also if you have any questions
regarding this video then please feel
free to ask away in the comments section
our team will reach out to you as soon
as possible thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here